tú
[Música]
en noviembre del 2014 yo me tuve la
oportunidad de aprovechar un viaje yo
les llamo tipo milagro porque son esos
viajes que cuando no tenés nada no tenés
pero ni sencillo en la bolsa y de
repente te dicen te ganaste una beca
para poder ir a estudiar a algún lado
y me fui llevaba solamente 60 dólares
para estar tres semanas en un lugar
donde un café negro valía 13 dólares
estaba yo en el lobby del hotel el día
que llegué
sin almorzar sin cenar eran como las 9
la noche y me fui a sentar a una de las
islas del hotel de lobby
era en seúl corea era fin de año
estábamos al menos 8 grados
ya estaba sentado ahí a la par de otra
persona que resultó ser un billonario
que se llama hoffman
ahora soy su fan y yo no lo conocía en
ese momento pero me llamó mucho la
atención
una persona pasó caminando en el lobby y
lo vio y se le acercó y le dijo ay nos
puede dar un autógrafo por favor
entonces como buen chapín
yo estaba así
para ver que era porque le llevo uno que
si era un libro de los que él escribió y
se lo firmo y se lo dio
cuando él me volteó a ver y saber qué
cara tenía yo
que se sonrió dulcemente va y me dijo
venid también a la convención la beca
que yo había ganado era para ir a
estudiar lo que es inclusión financiera
que también es uno de los objetivos de
lado de ese para tratar de erradicar la
pobreza en los países
y le dije sí sí aquí estoy veras va a
vivir vine precisamente a escuchar sobre
lo que es banca banca virtual y banca
sin sucursales y entonces él empezó a
platicar conmigo en una de las mejores
pláticas que ha tenido en mi vida duró
cuatro horas y me comenzó a explicar
como también él en su empresa dentro del
emprendimiento pasó lo que todos
conocemos como el valle de la muerte
cuando uno estudia estadística se da
cuenta que la parte más alta de una
curva digamos bueno digamos que esto es
una curva se llama cresta y la parte más
baja se le llama by y hoy me quiero
enfocar en lo que se le llama el valle
del valle de la muerte o sea la parte
más baja y más complicada en el
desarrollo de un emprendimiento a lo
largo de la vida empresarial de una
persona
cuando yo comencé el emprendimiento era
una empresa que se dedicaba a procesar
transacciones digitales como un método
alterno de pago para toda la gente que
no era bancarizada esto lo hicimos
porque a veces vengo de una familia que
estuvo muy bien acomodada pero luego
perdió todo y nos quedamos trabajando en
la calle con mis hermanos nos amarramos
con tape los zapatos no teníamos agua no
teníamos luz no teníamos para comer
teníamos que salir a ver que vendíamos
para para poder llevar 20 quetzales a la
casa que es un equivalente como de 2
dólares 50 para poder tener 1 o 2
tiempos de comida entre entre nosotros
y cuando estábamos en esa fase a mi
hermana que estaba casada una persona
les hizo una compra de los pocos bienes
que les quedaban y les pago una persona
muy conocida para ellos y les pagó con
un cheque de una cuenta de un banco que
ya no existía entonces eso para nosotros
fue un golpe bien fuerte y
económicamente super súper fuerte y
comenzamos a darnos cuenta que es un
error dentro del sistema financiero
porque los bancos saben que tienes la
chequera saben que tienes los cheques
pero no te los piden como requisito para
poder cerrar una cuenta lo que permite
que gente que no tiene escrúpulos y que
tienen muy malas intenciones puede hacer
ese tipo de cosas entonces comencé a
estudiar
todo lo relacionado a banca y finanzas y
nos dimos cuenta que existen no sólo ese
problema sino muchos problemas y que los
sistemas financieros tradicionales están
diseñados para que las personas nunca
puedan salir de la pobreza un ejemplo de
eso es si un banco nacional tiene un
total de 3 unidades y digamos que es una
población total de 3 personas y le
presta uno a cada uno de ellos se lo da
como un interés digamos de un 30 por
ciento eso suma que al año que ellos
tienen que devolver el dinero es 3.9
pero el total monetario del país es 3
nunca van a poder pagar ese punto 9
adicional por lo tanto nunca jamás van a
poder salir de la pobreza si entonces
comenzamos nosotros una empresa que se
dedicaba a bueno en ese momento era muy
obras normal en ese momento muy avanzado
a toque nízar
digitalmente llamemos a token izar datos
y transacciones para poder mantener el
valor del dinero
llamémosle llamémosle así
y entonces comenzamos una es este punto
digamos cuando tuvimos la idea y
comenzamos una travesía en donde
empezamos a invertir todo lo que
teníamos todos nuestros ahorros yo
renuncie de mi trabajo mi socio como a
los dos meses también renunció de su
trabajo y empezamos a esta línea que va
acá
dentro del emprendimiento hay cuatro
fases para desarrollar una idea que es
ideación esta parte de acá se le llama
incubación esta parte de aquí se le
llama aceleración y luego esta parte acá
se llama escalabilidad
cuando nosotros estábamos en esta fase
que es donde está la mayoría de
emprendedores nos dimos cuenta que no
había apoyo de nada ni de gobierno que
estaba comenzando en identidades
privadas y la mayoría de las entidades
que trabajaban tenían ciertos intereses
que no eran tal vez el el apoyo del
emprendedor entonces nos empezamos a
juntar como once o catorce personas
regularmente y al transcurso de un par
de años formamos lo que se llama ahora
la asociación de emprendedores de
guatemala de la cuerpo es todavía sigo
yo siendo presidente ya después de
cuatro años
y comenzamos con la idea de dar
gratuitamente toda la asesoría y el
acompañamiento al emprendedor que era
algo que nosotros no habíamos podido
obtener
actualmente hemos ayudado a más de
10.000 emprendedores y hemos dado más de
300.000 dólares regalados en capital
semilla para ayudar a la gente de
escasos recursos a poner su empresa ya
poder salir adelante
cuando nosotros cuando gane esa beca
para poder estudiar en korea íbamos por
esta parte acá todos nuestros recursos
todos absolutamente todos nuestros
recursos estaban invertidos en la
empresa que teníamos y entonces empieza
a ser bien complicado porque te das
cuenta que que eres un café porque tenés
mucho frío no te alcanza quieres tomarte
una sopa en tu casa porque la refri está
vacía no te alcanza debes dos meses de
luz te viene el tercer recibo con orden
de corte y entonces miradas como pagas
uno para seguir debiendo dos y te
empiezas a apalancar mi socio ya no
podía pagar el colegio de su nena
tuvieron que mudarse a la casa de sus
suegros yo me tuve que regresar a la
casa de mi papá porque ya no podíamos
pagar más la renta
y se empieza a volver un proceso bien
bien complejo el aguantar
cuando cuando vas por esta fase de acá
se te empiezan a romper los zapatos se
te empieza a haber gastado tu pantalón
porque lo tienes que estar lavando
constantemente para poder estar medio
semi presentable ante la gente con la
que estás buscando inversión con los
bancos que estás buscando créditos se te
empiezan a romper las camisas de aquí el
problema es que ya no parece por muy
presentable que estés digamos se nota
que estás en esta fase del valle de la
muerte
y de repente llegas a esta parte de aquí
y cuando yo llegué ahí colapse ya no
tenía dinero para comer ya no podía se
me arruinó el carro ya no lo podía
reparar con mi socio camina no caminaba
entre los dos caminábamos cada uno
aproximadamente 12 kilómetros diarios
para poder juntarnos a trabajar y poder
empalmar ideas para poder terminar de
desarrollar lo que estábamos haciendo
toda la gente nos decía dejen de
trabajar en eso porque no buscan un
trabajo busquen un segundo ingreso
pero es que no te da tiempo trabajábamos
15 o 16 horas diarias en lo que era esa
idea que no despegaba que no salía que
llegábamos con un inversionista y nos
pedía cambios que llegábamos con un
banco y nos decía pero necesitan una
garantía que llegábamos con los clientes
y los clientes nos decían bueno cuando
tengan el producto pues vengan y cuando
íbamos con los inversionistas para tener
el producto nos decía cuando tengan
clientes entonces vengan y es un ciclo
vicioso que no sabes que es primero si
el huevo o la gallina
yo recibía 23 a 25 llamadas diarias de
cobro le diría a todo el mundo era un
hoyo del que destapa su no para medio
tapar el otro y no pude salir de ahí
y es bien complicado porque regresas a
tu casa todos los días te sentás en tu
cama y tu único pensamiento es que estoy
pagando
o sea será que de verdad estoy en el
negocio correcto será que de verdad
tengo la capacidad para hacer esto mucha
gente depende de ti no no solamente tu
familia y el sustento que llevas a tu
casa estamos queriendo desarrollar
servicios financieros para la gente a la
que nunca le dan un crédito para la
gente que no sabe qué es ahorrar para la
gente que no que recibe 50 llamadas
diarias 93 cómo estaba yo sino que
recibe muchísimo más hay un crédito que
se llama la diaria
ciertos turistas internacionales digamos
les dan y tienen que pagar diariamente a
las personas aunque ya lo hayan pagado
completo como como sociedad podemos
ayudar a esta gente y eso era lo que nos
motiva nos motivaba a todos los días
y entonces nos pasó un milagro conocimos
en un evento una persona
qué
simplemente se identificó con el
problema que estamos trabajando y nos
comenzó a invertir dinero y luego esta
persona trajo a otra persona que vino a
invertir muchísimo más dinero y entonces
ya íbamos como por aquí seguíamos sin
dinero sin dinero para comer seguíamos
cambio bueno ya caminamos como 6
kilómetros porque pusimos la oficina un
poco más cerca y empezamos a tener
empleados ya podíamos ver visualmente la
aplicación en un teléfono porque
teníamos para pagar desarrollo y todo
ese tipo de situaciones
y de repente llegamos a esta parte de
aquí
y jeff me dio un consejo sumamente
valioso el cual sigo poniendo en
práctica y ya es me dice todo todo todo
lo que hagas hacerlo siempre con
excelencia porque el dinero sigue a la
excelencia entonces va a llegar un
momento en el que se van a cruzar
y cuando llegamos nosotros a este punto
de aquí
y le estábamos ofreciendo nuestro
producto a los bancos bien un banco nos
dijo miren yo no invierto en empresas
porque a mí me gusta saber qué hacer y
mandar entonces saben que pongan y un
precio se las compró y el año pasado
logramos vender nuestra empresa
aquí
y con ese dinero lo que hicimos es que
pusimos otra empresa que se dedica a dar
créditos de 25 dólares o de 100 dólares
a toda la gente que no le alcanza para
llegar a fin de mes
que para muchos tal vez no es mayor
ingreso pero para ellos es un cambio de
vida y nos ha pasado que vamos caminando
a veces en la calle y viene gente muy
joven y nos va a abrazar y si ustedes
ustedes me cambiaron la vida
gracias a ustedes puede poner un negocio
de venta de fruta
y entonces quiero compartirles
las cuatro cosas o los cuatro principios
básicos en los que nosotros nos basamos
para poder sacar adelante la idea que
teníamos adelante y la primera es
busquen siempre una necesidad que
resolver siempre la iv de una empresa no
se trata de qué producto tenés y qué
tanta publicidad la haces una idea es un
producto es quien necesidad viene a
satisfacer
y qué tanta necesidad tiene la gente de
tu producto
entonces lo que te recomendamos es que
busques gente que es la que pensás que
pertenece a tu mercado y convences a
hablar con ellos a entrevistarlos a
investigar su comportamiento y tratar de
definir si de verdad ellos tienen la
necesidad de la idea que tienes enfrente
lo segundo
busca una solución a ese problema y
busca otra porción del mismo mercado
a la cual le vas a ir a contar la
solución que pensás ojo no a describir
el producto que querés hacer o qué
quieres lanzar o el servicio sino la
solución por ejemplo nosotros queramos
productos financieros en esta parte de
acá nosotros les decíamos miren ustedes
conocen gente que les han pagado con
cheques sin fondos a ustedes les ha
pasado que el cajero automático les dice
que les dio el dinero pero no les da el
dinero y todo el mundo quienes de aquí
conocen gente que le ha pagado sin
cheque con cheques sin fondos por
ejemplo muchas gracias
ese es mi punto
y luego en la parte de acá nosotros
veníamos y les decíamos miren que
ustedes utilizarían dinero digital y les
explicamos que era dinero digital
ustedes se sentirían cómodos teniendo
dentro de un dispositivo como éste toda
esa información de tarjetas de crédito
de cuentas de bancarias de los créditos
que ustedes tienen y había gente que nos
decía así había gente que nos decía no y
nos enfocamos en los que decían que no y
en el por qué y comenzábamos a tratar de
adaptar la solución que estábamos
desarrollando en ese momento para tratar
de contrarrestar la mayor cantidad de
nos con los que nos encontrábamos
tercero tu mercado
y tratar de identificar quién es la
persona que tiene esa necesidad
para mí ha sido muy sencillo nosotros
ahorita trabajo en un banco al final un
banco paro contratando porque nos
dedicamos a asesorar ya diseñar toda una
transformación digital para el
desarrollo de productos financieros
digitales pero
el mercado en sí tiene que estar cómodo
con la solución que estás dando porque
recordarte que como bien dicen acá como
es el sapo es la pedrada no puedes poner
un precio si no sabes quién es la
persona que te va a pagar por ese
producto deja ahorita cuánto te va a
pagar que esté dispuesta a pagar no sé
si soy claro con eso
y después de eso buscamos el precio
ahora porque viene primero el mercado y
luego el precio porque precio es la
representación económica de una
necesidad otra vez y el precio es la
necesidad eso quiere decir que mientras
más necesidad de encontremos en la
problemática que queremos resolver mayor
disposición de pago va a tener la gente
para la solución que estamos proponiendo
y con esto no te quiero decir poner el
precio que querrás porque tampoco es
justo si no cobra lo que vale tu trabajo
ese es mi mensaje cobra lo que vales
cobra lo que estás diseñando cobrar lo
que les estás proveyendo al precio que
tiene que ser nosotros somos una cultura
bien compleja y somos una cultura que si
tú decís 10 te van a decir 7 le doy pero
valen valer y eso sea verdad pero como
querés vender entonces empezás a bajar
precios y empiezas a un montón de cosas
a mí me recordó cuando cuando yo no
estaba platicando me recordé mucho de
una vez en un trabajo que tuve estaba en
johannesburgo sudáfrica iba a salir y
viene el del hotel y me dice no no no
vaya caminando a ese museo no camine
porque somos el 64 país más violento del
mundo y le digo yo mira yo esta otra
persona yo somos de guatemala y esta
otra es de méxico o sea era cuarto
octavo lugar y primer lugar no nos va a
pasar nada estamos bien y a pesar que se
oye cómico es muy triste demasiado
triste porque eso hace que el 92% de
guatemaltecos que intentan emprender
fracasa en el primer año como último con
toda esta información que ustedes ya han
recopilado
rediseño en su producto busquen las
fuentes y les prometo que cada persona
con la que ustedes interactúen van a
pensar que ustedes lo diseñaron pensando
en ellos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]